first of all congratulations are in
order thank you how does it feel to be
on the red carpet here yes this is kind
of your first public outing as a couple
isn't it yeah coming out yes big deal
she's a beautiful lady
beautiful wickedly talented and amazing
and smart and I'm sure beautiful on the
inside too making you feel awkward
aren't we I don't see compliment well
thank you
I know but walking out that red carpet
I'm sure it felt good right yeah I don't
know if you realize but it was 20 years
ago that you want to go globe it'd be a
good time to reveal bag black him really
Vince wagon talented for a very long
time is like I'd like to say it how
would it feel to i repeat that tonight
oh it's always lovely you know it's
great but you know that the best part of
these things and we were talking about
it yesterday is that is that you know we
see all our friends and the people
creative and wonderful people that we
get to create you know celebrate their
express yeah and it's a thrill I see Ben
Stiller in it it just it just makes me
feel like it's Christmas morning I'm so
happy for him we love his show
and it's just exciting that way for me
I'm a bit starstruck so much fun stuff -
and February actually marks the 25th
anniversary of Ace Ventura pet detective
did you realize that no I know there's a
lot of anniversaries coming yeah we got
a favorite memory from that gee you know
we're just saying the other day I was
like the first Pearl Jam album came out
when I was in Miami that was pretty cool
yeah yeah I know we had a blast we had
so much fun on that thing that we
thought we were just gonna end our
career every time we went to dailies we
came out going I don't know I can't stop
laughing anybody's gonna understand this
like this is all I do I'll be happy
exactly and that's what it's got to be
it's got to be in the moment but where
we are you know I gotta ask you how you
guys met because though we do have a
Valentine's Day piece coming up so I got
a I've got about we won't we didn't mean
I'm kidding
kind of I was on another show that Jim
produced but we're co-stars on kidding
which is lovely and yeah and like I'd
say I wore a really sexy bald cap and
naturally tiny size and we started
seeing each other just a little bit
after she finished on the show and and
we just really hit it off
see very happy congratulations on
everything
[Music]